- Earlier this week, we asked Taylor Kenny
and his role on Chicago Fire
that if it helped him stay out of trouble
with law enforcement, so what about you?
Have you ever had any,
any luck in that area?
- I don't get pulled over a lot.
I don't get a lot of experience
with law enforcement,
but the last time I was
pulled over, I was speeding,
and he said, you know,
it was that whole thing,
do you know why I pulled you over?
I said, yes I do, I said, I was speeding,
I said, but here's the other thing,
I left the house without
my wallet this morning,
I don't have any government issued ID.
- Oh!
- But nothing government issued
and he said, well, I, I
think I recognize you.
You're an actor, right?
I said, yes sir, I'm
actually a very good actor.
(laughter)
He said, well, if you
give my wife an autograph,
I'll let you off with a
warning, you've been very honest
and you seem, you know,
you seem to have regrets.
I said, absolutely, what's her name?
He said, it's Lily.
I start writing an autograph to Lily.
He calls his wife,
says, hey honey, I'm
getting you an autograph,
I write, all my love,
he says, it's Jason Bateman,
I write Jason Bateman.
- What?
(laughter)
Oh my God.
You totally wrote Jason Bateman?
- I don't know.
Everybody came out a win.
- Oh my God, that's awesome.
- [Man] The officer's
happy, everybody's happy.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, that's awesome.
- I bet you imagine, somewhere,
Jason Bateman's happy too.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, that's
amazing, that's so awesome.
Somewhere, Jason Bateman
gets pulled over by a cop,
hey, I pulled you over,
he's like, no you didn't.
(laughter)
I don't know you.